cette menace est réelle et permanente à
l'existante toujours les services y sont
attentifs laurent nièce et le
coordinateur national du renseignement
et de la lutte contre le terrorisme en
septembre dernier il a l'air tous les
voyants sont au rouge la propagande est
dirigé contre nous ils nous sommes dans
un contexte de menace qui est toujours
très élevée on s'éteint marquée par le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre par
la campagne présidentielle ou encore la
propagande d'organisation terroriste
sunnite dirigée contre la france la
menace terroriste atteint des niveaux
très haut mais à quoi ressemble t elle
vraiment pour facture on dresse le
paysage du spectre terroriste en france
[Musique]
la menace en france est multiple même si
l'une d'entre elles est de loin la plus
dangereuse pour le comprendre il faut
regarder les chiffres avancés par les
services de renseignement depuis 2000
17,36 attentats islamistes ont été
déjoués et 23 ont été commis du côté de
l'ultra-droite 6 cellules ont été
démantelés sur la même période quand
seulement un projet venant de l'ultra
gauche a été déjouée même si elles sont
à des niveaux plus faibles ces deux
dernières inquiète l'ultra-droite
préoccupe part parce qu'on l'a vu
frapper à l'étranger il ya eu des
attentats très meurtriers je pense par
exemple à l'attentât de price cherche en
nouvelle zélande qui a fait une
cinquantaine de morts dans des mosquées
mais si on se limite même à l'europe et
à nos pays voisins en fête en 2020
l'attentât le plus meurtrier perpétré en
europe était un attentat de l'ultra
droite en l'occurrence perpétrés en
allemagne c'est inquiétant pour la
france c'est qu'on sait qu'il existe des
militants identitaires et qu'il existe
des doctrines appelant au passage à
l'acte terroriste il ya des ouvrages
mêmes qui ont été rédigées qui appelle
explicitement à commettre des attentats
dans l'idée que ça pourrait déclencher
une guerre civile est ce donc ce sont
des théories dites accélération nist il
s'agit d'accélérer une guerre civile
tant que le rapport de force démographie
est favorable au blanc chrétien quant à
la menace ultra gauche lc pantale
essentiellement à des actions contre
des intérêts matériels de voitures des
antennes relais des établissements
publics mais qui naturellement pourrait
basculer comme ça a été le cas par le
passé dans les années 70-80 pourrait
basculer vers un terrorisme encore plus
violent et vers des attentats ciblant
des individus et le fait que certains
militants des frères gauche et rejoint
les rangs kurdes pour combattre des ch
est aussi un point d'inquiétude pour les
autorités qui voient en eux une capacité
à prendre les armes et une connaissance
des techniques de guerre ce qui est des
autres menaces elles sont pour l'instant
anecdotique même si selon le chercheur
de l'ifra certaines mouvances commence à
prendre de l'importance celle qui a fait
le plus couler d'encre probablement ces
derniers temps stylet survivalistes avec
vraiment des idéologies parfois mêlées
pas très clair parfois proche de l'ultra
droite avec la pandémie d'ailleurs de
kobe 19 qui a pu renforcer les craintes
et puis qui a nourri aussi au delà de la
mouvance survivalistes un mouvement anti
élites antisystème avec des menaces très
clair qui ont été émises contre
certaines personnalités politiques qui
ont voté des mesures sanitaires mais
concentrons maintenant sur la menace
islamiste
quelle est la principale en france par
nature et parce qu'elle se cache il est
difficile de la quantifier avec
précision le fichier des personnes
radicalisées a considérablement grossi
depuis 2015 jusqu'à atteindre 28 23
mille personnes même s'il n'y a entre
guillemets que 8000 fiche dite active
c'est quand même considérable donc la
gaine mouvance radicale très importante
et toute la difficulté c'est qu'on ne
sait pas qui parmi cette mouvance peut
passer à l'acte une première manière
d'évaluer la menace terroriste s'est
tout simplement de voir le nombre de
morts alors c est tres nique mais en
même temps ça donne quand même un bon
indicateur et si l'année 2015 avec
notamment l'attentât contre charlie
hebdo puis les attentats du 13 novembre
a constitué un pic dans les statistiques
des victimes du terrorisme la france
connaît depuis une baisse très nette de
ces chiffres ceci étant on voit que les
velléités d'attac reste très élevée avec
des projets d'attentats y restent
fréquents et des projets qui pour la
plupart sont des jouets à épi a aussi lu
des attentats qui entre guillemets ont
réussi c'est à dire qu'ils ont produit
des victimes mais ces victimes sont
moins nombreuses parce que ce sont des
attentats qui sont - planifier moins
sophistiqués souvent perpétrés par des
individus passant à l'acte seul avec des
moyens très simples peut être est
amendée attentat à l'armé blanche pour
comprendre l'évolution du mode
opératoire il faut se pencher sur la
situation en syrie et la mettre en
parallèle avec la perte pour des shows
de son sanctuaire siro irakien en fait
depuis ce sanctuaire des che était
capable d'entraîner des commandos de
planifier des attentats sophistiqués
ambitieux et ça a donné en particulier
les attentats du 13 novembre 2015 en
france et ceux qui ont eu lieu en mars
2000 16 ans en belgique depuis que ce
sanctuaire a disparu à c'est-à-dire très
largement depuis 2010 est avec la perte
de jaca et mossoul et puis ensuite 2019
avec la perte du dernier réduit qui
arrose l'état islamique n'est plus
capable d'entraîner des commandos et de
les projeter à l'étranger la france
continue à être visé très régulièrement
par la propagande de l'état islamique et
d'al-qaïda qui
s'ils le pouvaient nous enverrait des
commandos aux terroristes et
probablement essaie de le faire même si
ce n'est pas la menace la plus probable
aujourd'hui est en revanche cette
propagande elle nourrit la haine
d'individus qui vivent en france et qui
sont adhérents à l'islam radical et au
djihadisme qui peuvent passer à l'action
influencé par cette propagande en
revanche ce sont naturellement tous des
individus qui ont été influencés qui ont
reçu la propagande de ces organisations
terroristes depuis 2019 les attentats
perpétrés en france l'ont d'ailleurs
tous été par des individus sans
connexion directe avec une organisation
terroriste
autre point d'inquiétude des autorités
la libération future de gros profils
islamistes en fait on a très largement
atteint le pic des terroristes en prison
pour bab le mans en 2020 et depuis les
sorties s'accélère avec maintenant des
gros profils qui vont sortir aujourd'hui
il ya environ 450 terroristes islamistes
en prison alors qu'on en avait plus de
500 en 2020
évidemment ça s'est traduit du cou par
une augmentation des terroristes en
milieu ouvert aujourd'hui on a plus de
300 terroristes placées sous main de
justice en milieu ouvert si elle seule
selon la fondapol la france concentre
près de 44% des attentats islamistes et
42% des victimes depuis 40 ans c'est
aussi parce qu'elle est privilégiée aux
côtés des états unis dans les menaces et
propagande des organisations terroristes
ce qui ne veut pas dire que les
islamistes ne s'entendent pas à nos
voisins grosso modo ils sont en guerre
de toute façon contre la civilisation
occidentale contre l'occident contre les
mécréants contre peu importe les
dénominations en revanche il est vrai
que la france est en tout cas en nombre
d'attentats la plus touchée ces
dernières années est souvent
particulièrement ciblés par sa présence
au sahel par ces loi contre le voile par
le discours du président l'an dernier
aux mureaux ce à quoi nous devons nous
attaquer c'est le séparatisme islamistes
tous ces facteurs là font que mais pas
depuis 6 mois depuis 15-20 ans la france
est de toute façon ciblée par le
terrorisme islamiste il ya toujours des
raisons pour l'islamisme de s'en prendre
à la france mais c'est vrai qu'elle est
particulièrement visée
[Musique]